[Musique]
non c'est vrai avouer que zoé del rio a
une présence particulièrement incroyable
à l'image moi je trouve qu'elle crève
l'écran
donc c'est un passe droit pourquoi quoi
ton passe droit si un jour zoé del rio
s'intéresser à toi tu reviens permis de
tromper mon amour ciseaux et del rio
couche avec toi je tape le dit
[Musique]
là
est-ce que ça va je tenais à l'hôpital
bon au lit
je ne vais pas tarder
on reste ici d'accord c'est le travail à
merveille tout à fait comment j'ai fait
quoi bas pour attirer une fille comme
elle ça veut dire quoi que je peux pas
choper une nana comme sow et qu'est ce
que tu crois pas retourner assez
d'appuis avec toutes ces filles à poil
constamment merde sont partout qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent à la fois tu leur coin et
montre une montre étanche à 200 m
qu'est-ce qu'on en a à [ __ ]
[Musique]
avant les trois gamines se serait quitte
enfin me tromper racquinghem passé voir
faire équipe car il faut d'abord se
connaître et je me livre
[Musique]
tous
bingo
quitte à conseiller cette coupe de
cheveux zoey l'advil tu ta conseil ta
robe rockin pignoufs évite de publier
cette merde se plaît à le faire faute
maintenant toi vas te faire [ __ ]
maintenant